Compound butter, lemon
juice, parsley, garlic, boom.
Really good.
In this MasterClass,
you'll be able to gain
even more knowledge.
But more important,
more confidence
in becoming the cook
that you want to be.
We'll be working on
techniques and recipes focused
on the bounty from the sea.
And we're gonna learn
how to do sous vide
cooking two different ways.
And then one of my favorite
courses in any meal, desserts.
Ah, right out of the oven,
just like grandma used to make.
One of my first jobs
was as a poissonnier.
And it was just an
extraordinary moment in my life.
I got to work with so much fish.
There's so much more variety
of fish than there is meat.
We're going to cook our
branzino in salt crust.
I want you to hear it.
Dover sole-- it's a fish
that has a very firm flesh.
And therefore, it's not
going to flake apart.
It's a pretty easy fish to cook.
To really get that
skin crispy, you
want to get all of that
water off of there.
You notice all the
moisture that's
accumulating along my knife--
beautiful.
This is something that I eat
maybe two or three days a week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Chocolate pots de crème--
it's a small dessert
but extremely rich.
You could use a milk chocolate.
You could even use a
dark milk chocolate.
My spoon goes in
nice and gently.
Look how smooth
and creamy that is.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I want you to be enriched
in your cooking technique
and therefore, be able
to nourish yourself,
your friends, and your family.
And you may make a
couple of mistakes.
And that's OK.
I've made countless mistakes.
But you just keep
moving forward.
I'm Thomas Keller, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]